atención maestros y maestras de todo el
perú
la convocatoria para la beca maestro
khan academy 2021 ha comenzado a ceder
de forma totalmente gratuita a
capacitaciones y diversas herramientas
pedagógicas que nos ayudarán a potenciar
nuestra práctica educativa a descanso a
fortalecer nuestros habilidades
digitales así como también a mejorar
nuestro relacionamiento con padres y
madres de familias
además aquellos maestros que culminen
con éxito los tres meses de la beta
maestro khan academy 2021 serán
acreedores de un diploma de
reconocimiento donde se detallará las
habilidades desarrolladas en esta beca
no esperes más las vacantes son
limitadas y sólo serán mil maestros y
maestros seleccionados postule e
ingresando a canicas de mil puntos
instituto apoyo punto ong punto que da
clic en el botón postulé aquí y complete
los datos solicitados
[Música]
[Aplausos]
verifica que hayas ingresado
correctamente tus actos y una vez
habiendo leído y aceptado los términos y
condiciones da clic en enviar
postulación aparecerá un mensaje de
confirmación
y listo de esta forma ya estás
postulando a la beca
recuerda que solo tienes hasta el 3 de
marzo para enviar tu postulación los
maestros y maestros que sean
seleccionados recibirán un correo
electrónico el día 8 además muchos
sortea todos a postular
ah
[Música]